[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
tonight a special edition appears morgan
unsensed it it's the late night shooting
that scandalized the country and made
headlines across the world
she's the stunning property developer
daughter-in-law of a billionaire british
lord he was a police chief in belize
married with five children what were
they doing alone on the dock at midnight
how and why did she end up shooting him
dead
this is the extraordinary story of
jasmine harten
and the death on the dock
it was a loud bang
my ears were ringing
i could see blood and feel the blood and
that's when he started slipping into the
water
it seems an odd thing to be doing on a
starry nightmare just the two of you
you are familiar with guns aren't you
you know how to use them in fire
i'm perceived to be this wild cocaine
addict party girl
[Music]
i still believe that she should still be
charged for murder
i'm definitely not a murderer
and i am being set up
it was a horrible night that changed
everyone's lives
[Music]
tonight a special edition of the show
and a story that simply has everything a
police chief shot dead sensational
claims of a murder hit on a cop and a
judge a powerful billionaire family and
at the center of it all a mother
separated from her children facing trial
jasmine harten
and the death on the dock
jasmine harten is the mother of two
children to andrew ashcroft a property
mogul in the caribbean paradise of
belize he's the son of lord michael
ashcroft a british billionaire former
deputy chairman of the british
conservative party and the most powerful
man in belize
the super rich family was already known
by almost everybody in the country but
what happened on the night of may 27th
last year has turned that fame into
infamy
jasmine harton broke a covey curfew to
drink on the dock beside her home with a
mutual friend henry gemma the police
superintendent
gemma was then shot dead
jasmine hartin was holding the gun
so why were they alone on the moonlit
waterfront and what really happened
before the death on the dock tonight
jasmine harten breaks her silence and
gives her first television interview as
she awaits trial in belize for
manslaughter by negligence it's set by
claims of an ever-changing story she's
made global headlines that sparked
scandalous rumors across her adopted
country to some she's a cocaine using
party girl embroiled in an affair with
the cops she shot dead two others a
mother caught in a tragic accident now
fighting one of the most powerful
families in the world what's very clear
is that just weeks before the shooting
she and andrew ashcroft at the opening
of their brand new luxury hotel appeared
to have it all today is a special day in
many regards personally for jasmine and
i it marks the fulfillment of a dream to
create the elia resort in belize in the
official opening day today nothing was
quite as it seemed and their lives were
all about to change forever as one man's
life was about to end
[Music]
so i suppose my question for you is is
to take you back to before you get to
this little jetty where you had this
late night drink with henry gemma i want
to take you to life before this incident
what was your life like in belize at the
time before this accident it was
exciting
i had my children
andrew and i had just opened alaya hotel
it had only been open for a few weeks
we were still ironing out the wrinkles
of the hotel um it was an exciting time
um
we were looking forward to the future
i've read varying reports about the
status of your relationship with andrew
ashcroft can you clarify whether it was
happy at the time or whether you'd have
problems
andrew and i
had a lot of issues in our relationship
um specifically the last year and a half
we were sleeping separately we were
keeping
appearances together andrew's family
thought that we were still very much an
item
my children didn't know
that we were sleeping separately we kept
it very hidden from them as well you see
just listening to what you've just said
in response to two questions
there's an immediate contradiction which
maybe you can clear up but when i asked
you what life was like you painted a
fairly idyllic picture of a very happy
existence with your family and your kids
and so on and when i asked you directly
about the status of your relationship
you paid a very different picture and so
people who are your critics as you know
they keep leaping on what they see is
apparent inconsistencies in your public
statements i can clarify that very
easily
i was very excited to split up from
andrew
uh i was excited that elia had opened
um i was happy to be with my children
happy for the future like i said um
i had already been emotionally done with
andrew
for a long time a year and a half almost
two years so
the prospect of being
able to move on with my life and stopped
pretending to be in a relationship with
him that was exciting to me so
elia had just opened
we were about to come out to the family
that we weren't together and i was
actually going to get my freedom
so when i say i it was happy positive
times it was
i was excited to have my freedom and to
be able to move on with my life apart
from andrew the reason i've i've asked
about a relationship is simply as you
know belize has been a gog with rumors
that you were having some kind of
other relationship with henry gemma
that's why you were out on this jetty
late at night by the ocean that's why
you were partying together what do you
say to those rumors well first of all i
met henry through andrew andrew was
friends with henry so
andrew was meant to come with us
and join us for a cocktail that night
last minute he decided to stay in and
not join us
it was also supposed to be
another friend joining us
as well henry had his friends staying at
the same unit so we weren't meant to be
by ourselves that just happened to be
that way
we also weren't partying i grabbed a
glass or a bottle of wine that had been
opened before
and i brought that with me i had maybe
two glasses of wine
so it wasn't a party um
and yeah the rumors of of henry and i
that's completely false we were friends
i knew him through andrew and it's just
a small country with a rumor mill and
they like to make something of a story
that it's not i mean part of the part of
the narrative is you know
from people who clearly
uh don't like you
but they've painted again a picture of
quite a wild socialite party girl there
are videos of you sort of dancing in the
rafters of restaurants and so on that
you were heavily into cocaine abuse
and drinking heavily
i know you've refuted those but why why
are people going around saying this kind
of stuff i've wondered the same thing
the only thing i can come to think of is
who would benefit from such rumors
obviously it would benefit in the
custody course it would benefit in many
ways if i'm
perceived to be this wild cocaine addict
party girl
it's just not true
on sensor next a private drink on a
moonlit dock a shoulder rub
and a fatal gun shot
i could see blood and feel the blood
so then
i tried to wiggle out from under him
and that's when he started slipping into
the water
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to a special edition of
piers morgan unsensitive this is the
story of jasmine hartin daughter-in-law
of british billionaire lord ashcroft
and the night she killed police chief
henry gemmat she just revealed how her
relationship with andrew ashcroft had
broken down but flatly denies
sensational rumors of an affair with the
man that she shot dead
the rumors of of henry and i that's
completely false
we were friends
i knew him through andrew and it's just
a small country with a rumor mill and
they like to make something of a story
that it's not
well just after midnight on the 28th of
may last year belizean police found
jasmine harten on the bloodstained pier
next to the apartment she shared with
her husband andrew ashcroft beside the
dock their mutual friend the police
superintendent henry gemmod was floating
dead in the caribbean sea
so how did he get there and why
you don't dispute that you fired the gun
that killed henry gemmat no it was a
very tragic accident
i don't ever remember touching the
trigger of the weapon
but i was holding it when it went off
that's correct on the night in question
you said that you were andrew was gonna
come with you and he didn't you end up
on this little jetty with henry gemma
he's a police chief he's married with
five children you've got a bottle of
wine
uh what are you what are you talking
about you've known him a long time what
kind of conversation were you having we
were listening to music i had my little
speaker with me
um
he was talking a bit about
his relationship about the day he had
henry was my friend
but he didn't often talk about his
personal things but that night he did i
think talk to you in more detail than
normal about the breakup of his
relationship all he did was mention that
he was single um after i think he said
14 or 15 years he was single and that he
had taken a medical leave
or a personal leave from work rather
but he that's the extent of what he
really said about that so you're on the
jetty it's it's
late night now we're heading towards uh
10 30 11 o'clock
you're having some drinks
and you're talking about quite intimate
stuff he's opening his heart to you and
then
um
there's he's got a gun a glock gun so
just explain to me why he has a gun
on him
i was curious as to why he brought the
gun onto the dock as well
um we were sitting on the balcony
and it was a full moon it was beautiful
so we said oh let's go sit on the dock
and he said before we went that he
wanted to go get his gun from inside
and i thought that was strange
i remember making a joke with him saying
well we're literally going
to the front yard
and he said he always brings it
everywhere with him so
he went and got it from the kitchen
counter and brought it out to the dock
right so he he goes and gets his gun and
he brings it to the end of the dock and
then you start to
play some sort of game with the magazine
with the bullets what were you doing
with them henry thought that it was
important for me to get my firearms
license
because he thought i needed protection
so this is the second time he's had me
handle his firearm
the first time was on a few days prior
to that
when i called for help i was
in an uncomfortable situation and he had
me handle his firearm that night he said
get familiar with it you should get your
license
so
then that night on the dock he brought
it out
he handed me the clip of the gun and
wanted me to practice
unloading it reloading it just get
comfortable
just playing with the magazine and the
ammunition i'm just listening to this
obviously call from you but it seems an
odd thing to be doing
at that time of night on the end of a
dock
on a starry night was just the two of
you to be handling guns with live
ammunition i thought it was empty
um
and i agree it was a weird thing to do
at that time
but
i hadn't seen henry during the day if i
did he probably would have had me
practice
earlier in the day
so jasmine
you were playing around with the
magazine and the bullets but you
yourself were not handling the gun is
that right i was practicing unloading
and reloading just the magazine
the only time i handled the weapon was
at the very end when henry asked me to
pass it to him
so he wanted me to pass him
the clip and at that point the clip was
already back into the weapon so
i was struggling to remove the clip from
the gun
again i wasn't handling the gun earlier
so i'm not familiar with the mechanisms
how to remove it
i didn't know if i was pressing the
right button or not
because earlier he had handed me the
clip so i hadn't had to take it out
before
so i was struggling with it
and that's when
the gun went off
i'll come to when the gun goes off in a
moment but before that he'd said to you
that his shoulder was hurting and asked
you to rub his shoulders yes yes he
asked me to rub his shoulder which was
weird because
he's never um
he's never asked me to do anything like
that but i don't think it was a sexual
thing i did it for him because i didn't
think it was a big deal for me
it's like therapeutic it's not something
sexual if someone's shoulder hurts
so right but by your own omission it's a
bit weird isn't it to be i mean this
guy's a married man albeit uh he said
he's separated you're uh effectively
married you have a common law marriage
uh he doesn't know anything wrong with
it uh from what you've told me just
seems a bit odd for you to be out there
you know nearing midnight on a
on a dock and there's this big police
chief asking you to massage his back
i could see how people would take it
that way for sure um but you have to
understand andrew was supposed to be
there with us so for me it was not a
sexual thing um at all at all and i
don't believe that was his intention
either if you were prosecuting i'm sure
you will hear this when you get to the
call
i'm sure they'll try and paint this
picture and say that you were
whatever you've been drinking
he perhaps made some unfortunate move on
you you'd had the incident the week
before which you even reported to him
of fearing something might happen
you yourself say it's a bit weird that
he's asked for this back rub and the
next thing he's dead
so you can see that if you if you want
to see you as somebody
malevolent in this story then there's
quite a lot of evidence there to point
to a scenario where you might feel
that you wanted to defend yourself
there's been many many different stories
that i've heard i've heard that
i've
i executed him i've heard that it was an
attempted rape and i was defending
myself
i've heard that i lured him there and it
was andrew that shot him i've heard
so many different stories
the truth of the matter is
it's none of that he's my friend he was
my friend
he did not make a pass at me
i considered henry like a protector
so
as much as the rumor mill will go crazy
over this situation
it really isn't
what they're saying it was a friend we
weren't meant to be alone andrew was
supposed to be there where
physically was
henry
at the moment he was shot dead i mean
how far away from you was he
he was sitting to my left
slightly on angle i had
my left leg bent behind him
and my right leg was straight so i'd say
i guess a foot or two away
your left leg was behind him
mhm when you realize the the gun had
gone off
what were your feelings it was a loud
bang
then
my ears were ringing i just
i was in shock
henry fell back on top of me
at that point i realized one of us was
hurt i could see blood and feel the
blood
so then
i tried to wiggle out from under him
and that's when he started slipping into
the water and i tried to catch him of
course he was
a lot bigger than me so i couldn't hold
him up
so no it's it's still very difficult to
talk about it i don't
i don't like to talk about it
it was a horrible night that changed
everyone's lives
and ended some so i have to live with
that for the rest of my life
and since the next shocking leaked
footage casts doubt on jasmine harton's
story that story is about to change
i don't remember saying that i shouldn't
have said it if i said it but i really
don't remember saying that at all i
really don't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
piers morgan offensive my exclusive
interview with jasmine hartin
daughter-in-law of the billionaire lord
ashcroft she just described the night
she killed police chief henry gemma in
belize
you don't dispute that you fired the gun
that killed henry gemmat
no it was a very tragic accident
i don't ever remember touching the
trigger of the weapon
but i was holding it when it went off
that's correct
so jasmine doesn't deny that she was
holding the gun that killed henry gemma
she insists it was a tragic accident
that it went off in her hand
while she was practicing on loading the
magazine that's what she told henry's
police colleagues and three days after
his death they charged her with
manslaughter by negligence
weeks later jaw-dropping footage of her
aired on local television
confirming beyond any doubt that her
ill-fated handling of henry gemma's
nine-millimeter glock was not her first
experience with a firearm
my experience watching that footage was
that jasmine hartman clearly handled a
gun before and was proficient in
handling guns so i put that to her
you are familiar with guns aren't you
you know how to use them and fire them
i'm not familiar with nine millimeters
no
right but i mean i've seen videos which
i know you will have seen too um of you
expertly shooting a watermelon for
example on the beach firing at a at a
range and you're certainly it seems to
me
a proficient shooter you know what
you're doing with a gun i greatly
disagree with you i've never owned a gun
in my life i've never owned a firearm i
grew up on a farm
where you know i had six brothers and a
father and they had shotguns so
i've seen shotguns i've never owned one
i've fired them
you know a few times but i'm not an
expert
and what that video doesn't show you is
the 10 times i tried to hit that
watermelon
and missed
and that video was shot by my ex
right i suppose the point i would make
is if i i don't know if that's true or
not i've got no reason to doubt you i'm
just saying that in the video clip you
look very proficient with a gun i mean
you look like you know what you're doing
with the gun that you're using to fire
the watermelon as you do at the range
and i suppose the reason i'm asking that
is that when this gun goes off you claim
you don't even remember firing the
trigger but even the most basic
uh person using a gun with the most
basic knowledge knows to fire a gun you
have to fire the trigger
right and i don't remember ever touching
that trigger on the gun so
i don't know what happened to be honest
i just
was trying to get the clip out
and it just went off i don't remember
ever touching the trigger so i'm not
sure if it was a faulty weapon or not i
really can't tell you how it went off
right but i mean it couldn't have fired
itself right i mean you know that from
your own use of guns somebody has to
pull a trigger on a handgun for it to
fire a bullet i've heard many different
things that there's you know if it's a
faulty weapon
then sometimes it could go off if it's
rusty if it's
i've heard many things but
it would be
yeah i'm not sure how much i can talk
about this because i'm still in trial
for this matter but
i definitely don't remember touching
that trigger at all and i doubt it would
have been rusty or faulty because it was
his current service glock
pistol magazine and he's the chief of
police so
i would assume it was up to date and
perfectly serviceable you would assume
that however the reports i received are
different
well the reports you received are
different and we're about to discover
that the reports she gave have differed
too jasmine harton is the only known
witness to the death of henry gemma her
version of events is at this stage the
only version of events that's led to
those closest to henry casting doubt on
her story not least as we'll see in a
moment because her story has changed his
sister cherry gemma is also a police
officer in belize she spoke to piers
morgan on sensing about his death
with him not being here
it is very sad
you can see
many days that the children
they're worrying
little henry would say
mom
how comes that it takes so long to call
me he usually calls me on my phone
so little henry is still waiting for
that call from his dad
thinking about
jasmine harton
i don't know when she is telling the
truth
she changed her stories so much
so i don't know which one of the the
story that she's given
is what actually transpired on the pier
that night
my brother
is so skillful
and careful with his firearm
he would never ever hand over his
firearm to anyone how could she
don't remember
pulling the trigger
and she claims that the firearm
was in her hand
it seems to be a very close range shot
that my brother received
to the back of his head
something that he didn't expect would
actually happen
so with the closeness
from the back of his head
that is execution style
that is to kill someone instant
so some of what she's saying i don't
believe
i still believe that she should still be
charged for murder
she have committed the crime
and our family
want justice
for the death of my brother
well jasmine harton is aware of the
claims made against him by members of
henry gemmell's family i asked her
directly about them
his sister has said that i lured henry
there for someone else to kill him his
other sister thinks that i
execution style murdered him his mother
thinks something else i i mean
everyone's
everyone's thinking their own story
you're saying that this is all a
complete accident
others including his family
are saying it was murder that you meant
to kill him for whatever reason
what is curious to me is that your first
story when
you were asked about it was that he'd
been shot by somebody from a boat
that was nearby
why did you say that
i don't remember saying that i shouldn't
have said it if i said it but i really
don't remember saying that at all i
really don't and i've tried i've been
told i've said it and i i don't remember
saying it so i'm trying to rationalize
if i did i must have been in shock i
must have
been scared i'm not sure
but i don't remember saying it but you
accept that that if you did say that
that was a complete lie because you knew
you'd shot him correct i mean from the
moment i was at the police station and i
gave my caution statement
my story has been
exactly what happened it was an accident
from the very beginning at the police
station i told them it was an accident i
told them i was trying to get the
magazine out the gun went off
i thought the gun was empty
um so that's never been different
what this story is about the passing of
the boat
that's
in my opinion a complete made-up rumor
and like i said i don't remember saying
that
um and i'm trying to rationalize why
that would even be going around
well senior police superintendent henry
gemma was a popular and well-known man
in belize
six feet two inches tall and nicknamed
the king by his family had five of his
own children and friends in all parts of
belizean society one of his closest
friends was sean quilen now a successful
chef he knew him from the age of six he
spoke to uncensored about the mysterious
death of his best friend
i consider him one of my best friends
and we grew up from i was like age six
right on to the time of his death which
was around 14 or 42 and he was destined
to become the commissioner of police
because that was his goal that was his
dream
he at the time of his death he was a
superintendent of police and and he just
rose the ranks so fast you know he was a
protector for his family he was a dad he
was a brother loving i mean his sisters
it was just in his dna to be protective
i think because of all his surroundings
family of all girls
he was always a protector he did it to a
fart and and he was a no nonsense guy
and this was at home with his children
his family
ah
me personally as a great friend and a
good friend i've never touched that gun
i don't think any of his children
they knew he had it on him and that was
off limits by anyone at all times i mean
at times she's probably being treated
very
lenient because of who she is to pull a
trigger in a man's head and kill him
i would probably i would not be on the
streets walking with with visitation
right so my children living and sleeping
in an air-conditioned room every evening
so
i don't understand what is going on in
jazz it's just like a a novel it's a
movie and we don't know what the
conclusion will be
uh
[Music]
we don't know where it go and remember
we only have one side to this story
the other person is dead
so has jasmine harton attempted to speak
to the friends or family of the man that
she's shot dead
have you reached out at all to the
family of henry gemma the man that you
killed
no so at first i wanted to talk to them
i actually wanted to set up a fund
um
and that's something i explained to
michael and to andrew that i wanted to
do a fund i wanted to reach out and
publicly apologize for the accident
um i haven't reached out to them because
i've been advised not to
they're actively
against me right now
whether they believe it was an accident
a murder or
a hit i mean
either way i've been advised by my
lawyer not to speak to them because it
could only
create more issues right now but i i
definitely want to i think it would be
good for everyone one day for closure
if you were able to speak to them what
would you say
i would really just say
how horribly
sorry i am for this accident
i i would tell them that not a day goes
by that i don't feel for them for their
loss
for the children
i wish i could take it back
that's
i just wish i could take it back i wish
he didn't bring his gun out i
i not a day that goes by i don't think
about the family and pray for them and i
just want this behind all of us and i
want us all to get some kind of closure
and i know that that it will never be
the same for them
and it will never be the same for me do
your own family believe you
does your father believe you for example
i don't actually speak to my father
but my mother's been here with me from
day one she definitely knows what
happened she's been with me while i'm
crying she comes in to the police
station every day while i check in i'm
having ptsd
she's there for my nightmares
so yeah my mom knows what's going on and
she believes me but
during this whole process i've really
just taken a step back from friends and
family because i just need to
fight and survive and get through this
so i don't really speak to them anymore
when did you stop talking to your father
i stopped talking to my father almost
right away um after the incident
he
he wasn't really understanding what i
was going through he said as long as my
mother's with me he won't send a dime
and he's been true to his word he hasn't
helped me whatsoever
well now strange from both her father
and her powerful in-laws jasmine harton
remains on police bail awaiting trial
she's required to report daily to her
local police station as she attempted to
do that late last month almost exactly a
year on from hemi german's death her
story took another shocking turn
reporting for bail she was slapped in
handcuffs and taken by boat to belize
city facing explosive new allegations
several weeks ago you were rearrested
because there were claims that you had
ordered a hit
a murder hit
on the chief of police
police police commissioner chester
williams and the magistrate involved in
your custody battle you were then later
released but uh was there any merit to
the suggestion that you were
making such threats or organizing some
kind of hit i'm actually very glad you
brought this up because
that was very recently that was sorry
very recent
that i was re-arrested
i have been detained and arrested for
ridiculous bogus charges and false
allegations
is it true as police commissioner
chester williams has now stated publicly
that you sent him a series of disturbing
messages which he said were threatening
that's not true at all
so i have sent chester messages um and
i'm more than happy to share each and
every one of the messages where i'm
asking him to please stop his attacks on
me
out of interest why why are you text
messaging the police commissioner at all
that's completely inappropriate isn't it
for somebody under
charges like you
no i i don't feel it's inappropriate i
met chester because he was a friend of
mine and a friend of andrews so chester
gave me his phone number it might not be
standard to write the commissioner but
keep in mind he was also my friend
and he has been writing me back over the
last year
um and yeah the shock that i experienced
reading the disclosure knowing what they
were doing
i don't think it's very wrong for me to
ask
the commissioner of police to do a
lawful investigation to follow his oath
and to be ethical i don't believe that's
wrong for me to ask that of him
on says that next jasmine harten opens
up on being separated from her children
and sets out her sensational defense
i'm definitely not a murderer
and i am being set up i really am this
is terrifying
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the special program so
jasmine hartin doesn't deny that she was
holding the gun that killed henry gemma
she does deny that sending text messages
to the current police commissioner is
unusual
why are you text messaging the police
commissioner
at all that's completely inappropriate
isn't it for somebody under
charges like you
no i i don't feel it's inappropriate
for all the questions about jasmine
harton's account of the night she shot
henry gemma in the allegations about her
conduct since she maintains that she's
not only innocent but in fact a victim
herself she feels cut adrift by her
estranged in-laws the ashcrofts who are
unquestionably among the most powerful
people in her adopted home lord ashcroft
owns media outlets and much of the
economy in belize andrew ashcroft has
now gained legal custody of their
children and left the country the story
continues to dominate headlines it's
taken a heavy personal toll on the woman
at the center of this crime mystery
you've had
obviously you've been through a total
nightmare if your version of events is
the correct one it's been a nightmare
time for you not least because you've
been separated from your your twin
five-year-old children you know what has
that been like for you as a mother
the hardest part about this whole thing
it's the fact that i haven't even been
able to process
what has happened
that accident happened
and
it was
such a perfect storm and a perfect
opportunity
for my ex-family to just completely
capitalize on a terrible tragic
situation
and exile me completely from my children
from my my family my staff my home my
business
um
it's like
they just completely
swiftly
moved so
so strategically to
exile me and just completely throw me to
the wolves i didn't even have a fork or
a plate to eat off of
everything i have now i've had to build
in the middle of this tragic events and
trying to rebuild myself
fighting for my children with no money
just it's been horrible absolutely
horrible
your father-in-law is lord ashcroft he's
a very powerful political figure
he was the former deputy chairman of the
conservative party here in the uk he's a
very rich
powerful man with lots of connections
um i mean i would imagine that he would
argue
that given the gravity of the situation
that you found yourself in where you
shot somebody dead
that he's acted
and the family have acted to protect
their family from you
i would disagree with that
um
michael and that family they are so
powerful in belize
they saw me
at the end of this horrible accident
hanging from the edge of a cliff
and they could have simply offered me a
helping hand
i could have gotten out of jail i could
have gone
back to my home with my children
and
processed
what happened and healed and been there
with my family
um that's what should have happened and
that's what they could have done just
but i want to ask you i mean
if you're convicted here
it could be that you don't see your kids
again for a very long time
given how young they are and how devoted
you were to them
what impact would that have on you my
kids are very confused they don't
understand what's going on they want to
be with me
and
i don't know where my kids are even
right now it's been over three weeks
since i've spoken to them all i know is
they got on a private flight andrew has
taken them out of belize and i don't
know where they are
so
unfortunately
it's already as if i am in prison
because i don't have my children with me
it's horrible i mean you're holding it
together
as you talk about this but i would
imagine
there have been quite a few tears shed
over this
i cry every day
i choose not to cry in public that's uh
it's just something i do in private
and i have to be strong because if i cry
and give up
he will win
he already has the business um
i think in my in my opinion
his ultimate goal is to have me behind
bars
um because it would just be so much
easier there's a very high chance that i
don't do any time at all with
manslaughter by negligence it's
typically a fine
and i've already done time so
i don't know what will happen but we
have to leave it to the courts to decide
there was a piece in a newspaper about
the case last week that ended
by concluding that you're due for trial
later this year that will be the be said
when we learn just who the real jasmine
harton is
murderous jezebel or a woman deeply
wronged and set up for a fall by a
vengeful dynasty yes i saw that article
i'm definitely not a murderer
and i am being set up i am
i i really am this is terrifying i've
only ever seen
things like this happen
in movies
i'm literally trapped
in a big unfair game
which is ironic because that's michael's
book where
captive lions are tranquilized and then
hunted
and i strongly can relate to that right
now it's such a small country
everybody's terrified of them
uh
they they own the bank they own the
newspapers
they own the economy of this country the
commissioners their best friend the
prime minister stays at elia hotel in
san pedro the problem you have with all
this is i mean all of that may be true
as far as i i have no idea um
what is indisputable
is that you fired the gun which killed
this man
that's indisputable wasn't it
i was holding the firearm when it went
off so
yeah but i mean they don't fire
themselves
do they like i said
it's dark i'm trying to release
the magazine
and
just to let you know so
you mentioned a comment about the the
shotgun that's a very different
mechanism than a nine millimeter gun
which i'm not familiar with at all so
if my hand touched the trigger
it wasn't intentional and i didn't know
it happened my focus was i wasn't even
looking at henry i'm looking at the gun
trying to get the clip out so he could
reload it so we could leave
um
and
i don't remember touching it so
i don't know how else to answer the same
question
you're going to find out your fate
uh soon
if you are convicted you may end up
doing present time you've already been
in prison what has that experience been
like for you we've gone from a life of
of luxury
to a life of the complete opposite
incarcerated
trust me prison in belize is not is not
fun not at all um
and
a lot of people were saying at first
that because of my relationship with the
ashcroft family that i would have
special treatment
that couldn't have been more wrong it's
almost like
because they they were trying to
overcompensate to make sure that i had
the worst treatment i was given a male
guard which is unheard of
i was given a cell with no windows a
toilet that didn't work that i had to
use a bucket to flush
i was made to clean public bathrooms
with my bare hands i was deprived food i
was deprived of water there'll be people
listening to you
and depending on their viewpoint they'll
either feel sorry for you because they
believe your version of events
or they don't believe your version of
events
won't have believed what they've been
watching in this interview and i'm sure
there will be some
on both sides
but there are those who don't believe
you who think you deserve
all of that and more and should probably
not come out of prison for a very long
time
this goes back to i don't understand
what
what would be fair for an accident as
far as justice um
people say some some comments are you
know lock me up i deserve to spend my
life in jail but then there's other
people with the exact same charge as me
that has been maybe driving the car and
accidentally caused uh fatality and
those people pay a couple thousand
dollars and they don't spend a day in
jail so
it's like i i don't understand
why
an accident should cause me to have to
spend years in jail well because it
ultimately it comes down to whether
people believe your version of events
and there's obviously no correlation
between a car
and somebody firing a gun at point-blank
range and shooting somebody in the head
dead i mean there's no comparison so it
really it comes down to whether people
can believe you doesn't it ultimately
it's your word
so i think that ultimately
what's on my side here because there are
no witnesses it was myself and henry on
that pier
my
evidence and the forensics those are my
witnesses
so everything i've said to the police
from day one
has been collaborated
um which is why i'm facing the charge
that i have
well we write to andrew ashcroft his
representative denies jasmine harton's
claims and says she's received the best
legal support available in belize a
spokesman said mr ashcroft's sole
interest is the welfare and privacy of
two young children consistent with that
he's provided information only to the
custody court moreover his very
significant financial and other
contributions to ms harton's defense and
protection following her arrest put a
lie to any claim that miss harton was
thrown to the wolves
the reverse is true
well there are many remaining questions
aren't there about the night that henry
gemma was shot dead some of them may
never be answered
really only jasmine harten knows what
happened that night on the dock why they
were there why they were playing with
guns
why the gun went off without her
apparently remembering having pulled the
trigger
maybe a court case will unravel the
truth the changing story the tabloid
storm and her behavior since that tragic
night have all led some to cast doubt on
her character in the court of public
opinion ultimately of course it'll be a
court of law that determines her future
she's our waiting trial for man
slaughtered by negligence later this
year it'll be a courtroom that she now
needs to convince
jasmine as you know a lot of people just
don't believe you
they think you're lying they think that
you deliberately shot him dead
how can you convince them
that that's not the case
i'm almost tired of trying to convince
people to be honest it's been
a year it's been over a year
i know my truth
the evidence
the evidence supports what i said it was
a horrible accident i have no reason to
ever want to hurt henry
there's no reason at all for that
so honestly
i know my heart's clean in this
situation i have to live with a horrible
accident
i have
terrible memories of that night that i
will never get through i'll never be
past that
but i'm tired of trying to convince
people
of my innocence in this
um and the fact that it was a terrible
accident i
i just need to really live for my my
children and to fight for my life right
now
i don't have the energy to try to
convince people otherwise
so that was that did she convince you
you've heard from me you've had a lot
from jasmine harton but what did you
think i want to hear from you the
viewers you can send me a video response
by email
dm pm
talk dot tv that's all for tonight
whatever you're up to
keep it uncensored
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years of fleet street
there's loads of stories i could tell
you but actually i think i did an
overnight show for tall radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking um that romaine had won and
at half past two port of three after
nigel farage had already said he lost it
turned out he hadn't lost and it turned
out we were leaving the european union
so that was quite shocking
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zoro suleiman rishi
sunak has launched his bid to become the
new conservative party leader and the
next prime minister the former
chancellor helped trigger the mass walk
out of ministers when he resigned on
tuesday which helped to bring down boris
johnson's government more than a dozen
more tourists are now expected to throw
their hat into the ring to become prime
minister
zakir stama and angela rayner have been
cleared by durham police over the
beergate scandal the labour leader had
promised to resign if fined over a curry
and a beer with his staff whilst they
were working and the final brit is out
of wimbledon cameron norrie was beaten
in the semi-final by novak djokovic who
will play nick kyrios in the final on
sunday
but that's all for now we'll have more
after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you